Kim and Kanye's baby has a name the
significance behind their pick+
the new music Friday jams were bumping
this weekend okay first of all I'm sorry
guys I swear I did not know I'd be
talking about the Kardashians so much
this week but we've got a name for
Kenya's baby and I got to talk about it
hence the easy neutrals right Kim made
the big reveal today that their baby
girl's name is Chicago West Kanye was of
course born and raised in Chicago
Illinois so the name obviously has
special meaning to him I'm not gonna lie
I thought it was a little too on the
nose at first but a source tells et not
only was Chicago where Kanye started to
thrive as an artist but his late mother
was also very connected to the city so
this is likely an homage to her
beautiful right plus I'm really digging
the Abreva
the family will call Chicago Shai for
short just like they call it North nori
so that's cute and apparently North has
taken to her baby sister a source tells
et she was very jealous when st. was
brought home but she's matured a lot and
now she's just so happy our source also
says Kim and Kanye are on top of the
world right now and their home has been
a revolving door of family and friends
quote it's such a festive happy time in
their lives they just feel really
complete right now all right I want to
hear your thoughts on the name Chicago
West are we into it or over it well as
Kim K reveals her baby's name is Justin
Timberlake ready to have more kids
JT tells beats 1 radio hoes Zane Lowe
live with his three-year-old son Silas
is a blur but he wants to make him a Big
Brother parent talk is that the plan
more I mean I want to have as many as as
we can if I'm being honest
well Justin is about to give birth to a
different kind of baby February 2nd his
new album man of the woods drops and
then two days later he takes on the
Super Bowl halftime stage Justin also
just released his new song and his
social statement in this dystopian new
music video for supplies kicks off our
new music Friday playlist
[Music]
I'm curious what you guys think of this
one because just like his lead single
filthy I'm confused
what about this screams man of the woods
also these are not the jams I'd expect
in the spectacle that is the Superbowl
halftime show
am I crazy someone let me know am I
missing something all right moving on to
the latest from the chainsmokers check
it out this is called sick boy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the dudes are giving me some twenty one
pilots vibes in that one and I do
appreciate them doing something a little
different than those box you heard over
and over again on the radio so I'm gonna
give you guys some props finally I had
to leave you guys with one turn up song
and it comes courtesy of cashmere cat
and Major Lazer featuring tory lanez
this is miss you
[Music]
now if you like that one and the rest of
my new music Friday picks will link
those videos in the comment section for
you guys before I go this Sunday is the
Screen Actors Guild Awards ET will be on
the red carpet and you can head over to
our website or right now for our
interview with the SAG Awards the first
host ever Kristen Bell we're also
breaking down who we think will walk
home with the actor when the awards are
given out Sunday live on TNT and TBS and
then come hang with me Monday morning
for a special live episode of the daily
Denny breaking down what you guys didn't
see on TV all right I'll see you guys
then